but the majority of men are good men  it's a very no it's a very small  percentage of men that are sleeping with  all the women like it's a very like if  you want a guy that's over six foot  that's fifteen percent of men you want  to be cute cut that in half you wanted  to make money cut that in half it's a  very small percentage of men that are  sleeping with all the girls like every  girl has a guy in their friend zone that  would treat them well and they know  would treat them well and they know  likes them and it's like we don't pick  them and then we're gonna cry because  the guy we picked is bad to us but you  could have picked the guy in the friend  zone